oh my god it's been far too long it's
been far too long i opened our gmail
and there was
aldo jones saying he released the
spider-man no way home trailer saying
he'd love to see our reaction
i said
new number who dis
and he laughed hard and said that joke's
not old that joke is
has always been funny
from the first day
and never a predictable punchline and
that's what makes him a comedic genius
is recognizing
great let's just watch this the new
weird trailer reveal though jones hey i
missed him
spider-man no way home let's do it
ever since i got bit by that spider
i'm gonna cry only one week
we just like stay up here all day
it is so crazy down there
listen i did not kill mysterio the
drones did the drones that are yours you
son of a [ __ ]
you're gonna fry
[Laughter]
devil in disguise oh god
jesus christ it's okay
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you please we're safe to have the
universe together i think we're beyond
you call me sir okay
[Laughter]
parker spiderman
spiderman spiderman does whatever stop
tampering with the spell danny
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
[Music]
well i made this friendship bracelet for
you uh you know i'm not really a jewelry
person you don't have to wear it no i'm
going to wear it forever
we started getting some visitors
give me a rent
there are others out there we need to
send them back
hello peter so
scooby do this crap
the hell with that we've got six grand
men wanting to get physical with peter
this isn't scooby-doo this is lauren
daughter svuh
scooby-doo this crap
i miss the part where that's my problem
scooby-dooby-doo this crap what else
could we do these crap when you fix this
damn door good night
please
scooby-doo this crap
[Music]
my name is peter porker do you know
peter parker who's spider-man yes is
that him no
it's an orange
[Music]
that's disgusting
all these guest appearances nice
yes
hey parker
[Music]
holy [ __ ] it's my birthday
[Laughter]
happy birthday
oh my god
[Applause]
oh boy
[Music]
use three different spider-man shots
oh no
that's a great use of that insert
what if they all did come on that bridge
you're just a fake spiderman
cool
[Music]
i'm peter by the way um i'm spiderman oh
you're using the made up names um
i'm spiderman then
[Music]
a plus
fantastic work man that that was magical
fantastic work fantastic work dude i
can't
can't believe you're back it was
interesting watching this because it was
like the wild wacky aldo jones and then
the last minute or so it became like an
actual cool fan bait trailer
it became
half of like those trailer concepts
where they mash it together in the half
of aldo jones in in that last minute and
i was uh pleasantly surprised with that
i'm like he's actually going for some
badassery i don't know and and filling
in that last shot with all three of them
lunging at the three you know huge ones
getting the kick in on lizards like turn
into mighty raccoon yeah well that's the
thing it's like it also becomes the sort
of feat of you are kind of bringing us a
bunch of stuff we've just been hoping to
see yeah man and also you're you're uh
keying you're you're splicing out in
these moments some of them look flawless
yeah yeah
yeah with the other spiderman or like
green goblin that pizza the pizza
i really wish the doctor strange would
use more you know
like pizza ingredients or vegetables or
things like that in his spell casting i
feel like that's very befitting of the
sorcerer supreme and the problem is now
i'm going to see the movie and i'm just
going to think of a pizza the second
they get into yeah
because yeah dude that last minute you
on on the freeway fight i remember like
when the first trailer came out a lot of
speculation was coming into play of did
they you know cgi out the other two
spider-man on that one center frame shot
of him with the iron spider when he's
turning around this sequence you like
quadruple down here you brought in like
aunt may you brought in all the villains
you basically made the epic collision of
the fight happened here in the final
moments and while it still maintained
that aldo jones cheese
it's still like kind of gonna a pretty
cool freeway fight actually you know
it's the perfect combination because
it's it's equally as funny as everything
or you know it holds up comedically to
your body of work but then i also got
lost in yeah the fantasy fulfillment and
also because everyone's been joking
about like what about dane dehaan you
know what about these other characters
we know aren't coming back and i loved
the use of aunt may across this really
it made me miss rosemary best anime in
my opinion
all right guys well thanks so much for
being here i just realized one shot he
had happy frowning i get it
sadie uh yeah subscribe to aldo john's
even done so already this should be your
time to rain dude bully mcguire became
most popular in my eyes because of you
that's a sincere statement i'm gonna cry
i feel like the bully mcguire meme is
really popular but i first really
recognized it with your usage subscribe
to our jones hit that like button and
let's do a pic
guys i usually choose who we're gonna
shout out and every time it gets handed
off to john
for some reason he always chooses
pandemic jones because aldo jones is a
jones and you're a jones maybe you guys
are related somewhere distantly down the
line enough so to make this more than
just a tangential link between your two
names you're one of the sweetest people
at our patreon you're always here with
such enthusiasm
if there's anybody who would never
succumb even with the influence of a
symbiote to being a bully it's you
pandemic jones you always make me feel
good even just seeing your little avatar
i feel 10
lighter in my chest and i credit that to
you you take a little bit of stress off
my life and you make me feel better
about myself why don't you go ahead and
pick out some easter eggs hidden clues
and maybe wind up in the next
video so that we can get a good look at
you
but anyway you love shouting him out
hope you're having a good holiday season
friend
[Music]